and just as I was finishing editing the
video you about to see llama 3 was
dropped by meta but rather than do a
full video on that I'm going to give you
the tldr that's because meta aren't
releasing their biggest and best model
and the research paper is coming later
they have though tonight released two
smaller models that are competitive to
say the least with other models in their
class note that llama 370b is
competitive with Gemini Pro 1.5 and
Claude son it although without their
context window size and here you can see
the human evaluated comparisons between
llama 370b released tonight and mistol
medium Claude Sonic GPT 3.5 what meta
appear to have found although there were
early glimpses of this in the original
llama paper is that model performance
continues to improve even after a model
is trained on two orders of magnitude
more data than the chinchilla optimal
amount so essentially they saturated
their models with quality data giving a
special emphasis to coding data they do
say that they're going to release
multiple models with new capabilities
including multimodality conversing in
multiple languages a longer context
window and stronger overall capabilities
but before we get to the main video here
is the quick comparison you're probably
all curious about the mystery model
that's still training versus the new
gpc4 turbo and Claude 3 Opus for the
infamous MML U the performance is about
the same for all three three models for
the Google proof graduate stem
assessment the performance is again
almost identical with Claude 3 just
about having the lead for the coding
Benchmark human eval although that's a
deeply flawed Benchmark GPT 4 still
seems to be in the lead for mathematic
somewhat surprisingly many would say gp4
crushes this new llama 3 Model so
despite the fact that they haven't given
us a paper we can say the two smaller
models released tonight are super
competitive with other models of their
size and and that this mystery model
will be of a gp4 and Claude 3 Opus class
and now I must move on from llama 3
because I think in the last 48 hours
there was an announcement that is
arguably even more interesting using
just a single photo of you we can now
get you to say anything have you ever
had maybe you're in that place right now
where you want to turn your life around
and you know somewhere deep in your soul
there could be some decisions that you
have to make it is proving much easier
than many people thought to use AI to
imitate not just human writing voices
artwork and music but now even our
facial expressions and by the way in
real time unlike Sora from open AI but
what does this even mean for one I think
it is now almost certain that you will
be able to have a realtime Zoom call
with the next generation of models out
later this year I think that will change
how billions of people interact with AI
how intelligent those models will be and
how soon has been the subject of a
striking new debate this week of course
I'll cover that controversy over the new
and imposing Atlas robot AI nurses
outperforming real ones and much more
the Vasa one paper from Microsoft came
out in the last 48 hours and I've read
the paper in full and I'm going to give
you only the most relevant highlights
but why pick out Vasa when there have
been papers and demos of relatively
realistic deep fakes this year well it's
all about the facial expressions the
blinking the expressiveness of the lips
and eyebrows surprises me still I ran it
on someone just last night uh it was
fascinating you know she had complained
of she had complained of shoulder like
pain in her arm it was no model at this
resolution has been this good I think a
significant segment of the public if
this for the first time with no prep
could believe that these were real you
can control not only the emotion that
the Avatar is conveying from happiness
to anger also their distance from the
camera and the direction of their gaze I
would say that we as readers are not
meant to look at him in any other way
but with disdain especially in how he
treats her his daughter okay but of
course he is able to clearly see through
Morris and even though the Vasa one
model was only trained on real video
which I'll get to in a moment it can do
things like this I'm a papazzi I don't
no Yi
I I tell the truth from what I see
andell it toz Hil and the creators of
Asa say this in the first page of their
paper this paves the way for realtime
engagements with lifelike avatars that
emulate human conversational behaviors
at the moment the resolution is almost
HD at 40 frames per second they also
mention which is crucial negligible
starting latency let me try to
demonstrate again all you need is an
image and an audio clip from anywhere AI
generated or otherwise you know what I
decided to do I decided to focus now
somewhat ambitiously the authors
mentioned that this technology will
amplify the richness of humano human
interaction I would more agree with the
end of the paragraph where they talk
about the social interaction in
healthcare a few weeks ago we learned
that hypocritic Ai and Nvidia had teamed
up to release less than $9 an hour AI
nurses I'll show you the performance
metrics but here's a taster this is
Linda calling from Memorial Hospital on
a recorded line is this Albert woo yes
it is wonderful I'm calling on behalf of
Dr Brown your cardiologist to protect
your privacy can you please share your
date of birth it's January 1st I me
she's not trying to kill me right I
thought that after all these years of me
teasing or she's finally trying to get
back at me rest assured your wife isn't
out to get you and there's no need to
worry about a negative interaction with
your listen oil your latest lab results
show your potassium levels are within
the normal range which is between 3.5
and 5 and according to ratings given by
human nurses these AI nurses even
without a video Avatar outperformed in
terms of bedside Manner and educating
the patient on a technical level they
outperformed in identifying a
medication's impact on lab values
identifying disallowed over-the-counter
medications and way outperformed in
detecting toxic dosages so now imagine
your next nurse appointment looking like
this I'd love to begin with you firstly
just because I I read that you started
out an advertising and now you run a
wellness business these principles will
not only make your user's Journey more
pleasant they'll contribute to Better
Business metrics as well users hate
being interrupted and they hate getting
broken experiences keeping these
principles in mind in your app design
makes for a better user Journey now
let's briefly touch on their methodology
what they did so differently was to map
all possible facial Dynamics lip motion
non- lip expression eye gaze and
blinking onto a latent space think of
that as being a compute efficient
condensed machine representation of the
actual 3D complexity of facial movements
previous methods focused much more just
on the lips and had much more rigid
Expressions the authors also revealed
that it was a diffusion Transformer
model they use the Transformer
architecture to map audio to facial
expressions and head movements so the
model actually first takes the audio
clip and generates the appropriate head
movements and facial expressions or at
least a latent variable representing
those things only then using those
facial and head motion codes does their
method produce video frames which of
course also takes the appearance and
identity features extracted from the
input image very deep in the paper you
might be surprised by just how little
data it takes to train Vasa 1 they use
the public Vox celeb 2 data set I looked
up and it calls itself a large scale
data set but it's just 2,000 hours for
reference YouTube might have 2 billion
hours and we know according to leaks
that open aai trained on a million hours
of YouTube data now I know this data set
is curated but the point remains about
the kind of results you could get with
this little data now In fairness they
did also mention supplementing with
their own smaller data set using 3,500
subjects but the scale of data remains
really quite small but here is the
15-second headline comparing their
methods to real video and previous
methods the lip syncing accuracy is
unprecedented and the synchronization to
the audio is state-of-the-art the video
quality is improved but of course still
far from reality they say they're
working on better imitation of hair and
clothing and extending to the full upper
body now for Fairly obvious reasons
Microsoft are not planning to release
FASA 1 and say we have no plans to
release an online demo API product or
any related offerings until at least we
are certain that the technology will be
used responsibly and in accordance with
proper regulations I'm not quite sure
how you could ever be certain of that so
likely a Vasa one equivalent will be
released open source on the dark web in
the coming years now of course to get to
her levels of realism we'd also need an
AI to analyze our own emotions are you
social or antisocial I guess I haven't B
been social in a while mostly because in
your voice I sense hesitant would you
agree with that I I something hesitant
yes no sorry about something hesitant I
was just trying to be more accurate
would you like your OS to have a male or
female
voice female I guess but you're probably
not surprised to learn that there's a
company focused squarely on that Hume AI
I'm going to start a conversation and
have the AI analyze the emotions in my
voice should be interesting tonight I am
actually debuting a new newsletter
called signal to noise and the link will
be in the description I'm pretty pumped
determination calmness I don't think I'm
that calm concentration okay I'll take
it and yes that wasn't just to test hum
AI That's a real announcement I have
worked for months on this one and I'm
really proud of how it looks and sounds
it's free to sign up and the inspiration
behind the name was this as all of you
guys watching on YouTube know there's a
lot of noise around but not as much
signal and on this channel I try to
maintain a high signal to noise ratio I
basically only make videos on this
channel when there's something that's
happened that I actually find
interesting myself and it will be the
same with this newsletter I'm only
actually going to do posts when there's
something interesting that's happened
and more than that I'm going to give
every post a does it change everything
dice rating that's my quirky way of
analyzing whether the entire industry is
actually stunned so absolutely no spam
quality writing at least in my opinion
and a does it change everything rating
that you can see at a glance each post
is like a 3 4 minute read and the
philosophy was I wanted a newsletter
that I would be excited about and only
for those who really want to support the
hype free ethos of the channel and the
newsletter there is The Insider
Essentials tier you'll get exclusive
posts sample Insider videos and access
to an experimental smart GPT 2.0
absolutely no obligation to join I would
be overjoyed if you simply sign up to
the free newsletter whether you're
subbing for free or with Essentials do
check your spam because sometimes the
welcome message goes there as always if
you want all my extra video content and
professional networking and tip sharing
do sign up on on AI Insiders on patreon
at least so far I've been able to
individually welcome every single new
member but of course while deep fakes
progress robot agility is also
progressing here's the new Atlas from
Boston Dynamics
now the other most famous robot on the
scene is the figure one which I talked
about in a recent video and just 2 hours
ago the CEO of the company that makes
fig1 said this speaking of Boston
Dynamics new Atlas won't be the last
time we get copied if it's not obvious
yet figer is doing the best mechanical
design in the world for Robotics and he
was referencing the waste design of the
new Atlas robot now whether that comment
is more about PR and posture only time
will tell but before we completely leave
the topic of AI social interaction and
her here's Sam mman from two days ago He
suggests that the personalization of AI
to you might be even more important than
their inherent intelligence and the
long-term differentiation will not be I
don't think the base model like that's
just you know intelligence is just like
some emergent property of matter or
something the long-term differentiation
will be the model that's most
personalized to you that has your whole
life context that plugs into everything
else you want to do that's
like well integrated into your life but
for now the curve is just so steep that
the right thing for us to focus on is
just make that base model better and
better I do start to wonder if that's
part of a deliberate strategy from open
AI in my recent Stargate video I talked
about how Microsoft are spending $100
billion but this week hasab said that
Google will be spending more than that
on compute so if it is true that Google
starts to race away with the power of
their models that could be one way that
open AI competes get more data from more
users and personalize their AI to you
likely with a video Avatar and don't
forget we got very early hints of this
with the GPT store open AI are now
paying us Builders based on user
engagement with their gpts at the moment
that using engagement is apparently
really quite low but throw in a lifelike
video Avatar and that might change quite
quickly of course those models would
only become truly addictive for many
when they were as smart as the average
human there are those though of course
that say that's never going to happen
including the creators of some Cutting
Edge models here's Arthur mench
co-founder of mistol the whole AGI
rhetoric artificial general intelligence
is about creating God I don't believe in
God I'm a strong atheist so so I don't
believe in AGI I'm not personally sure
about the link there but it's an
interesting quote then we have Yan Lun a
famous llm skeptic he's previously said
that something like AGI definitely
wouldn't be coming in the next 5 years 3
days ago he said this there is no
question that AI will eventually reach
and surpass human intelligence in all
domains but it won't happen next year he
then went on in parenthesis to say that
auto regressive llms May indeed
constitute a component of AGI that does
seem to me to be a slight change in
emphasis from previous statements others
like the CEO of anthropic have much more
aggressive timelines for the context of
what you're about to hear from Dario Ade
ASL level 3 refers to systems that
substantially increase the risk of
catastrophic misuse or show low-level
autonomous capabilities whereas AI
safety level 4 indicates systems that
involve qualitative escalations in
catastrophic misuse potential and
autonomy on timelines just this week he
said this when you imagine how many
years away just roughly ASL 3 is and how
many years away ASL 4 is Right you've
thought a lot about this exponential
scaling curve if you just had to guess
what are we talking about yeah I think
ASL 3 is is you know could easily happen
this year or next year I think ASL oh
Jesus 4 I could imag no no I I I I told
you I'm a Believer in exponentials I
think ASL 4 could happen anywhere from
2025 to 2028 so that is fast yeah no no
I'm I'm truly talking about the near
future here I'm not talking about 50
years away so according to who you
listen to AGI either doesn't exist or is
coming pretty imminently but I have to
end as I began with her some say that
the movie Her was set in the year 2025
and that's starting to seem pretty
appropriate now whether or not it's
actually released I do think we Humanity
will be technologically capable of
something approximating her by next year
let me know if you agree thank you so
much for watching to the end of the
video please do check out my new
newsletter I'm super proud of it and as
always have a wonderful day